what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes we are the
beginning of the vulture might war
part one i guess officially the villager
my war the last video was more of a
prelude than anything else but this is
how it all starts
probably the single greatest story arc
in the entirety of the invincible
run so one of the first things we do
here is we basically pick up with alan
the alien
and nolan omni man yes and they are
looking for a guy by the name of tech
jacket now tech jack is kind of a cool
concept here in the invincible comics
and it's one of the things where kirkman
kind of does this slow build and that's
one of the things i hope you guys are
kind of noticing over the course of the
invincible run
that there are a lot of similarities
between like dc comics
and marvel comics and invincible but of
course it's on a much smaller scale
right now i will say that i think that
what's going
on here with regards to the kind of
spacefaring escapades
insofar as the action you see is a lot
bigger than dc right now if it's not
green lantern you never really see
anything about space and dc comics but
with marvel you see stuff in space all
the time thanks to dan abnett in 2006 in
annihilation it became an even bigger
thing after that up to that point it was
just small little things here and there
but the cool thing here is that tech
jacket
is basically there with his dad and it's
one of those little situations where you
kind of have omni man and you've got
alan who were just kind of like i mean i
don't really know
exactly where this guy is but supposedly
this is his house
he kind of vanished at some point along
the line but like i don't know how
powerful this guy is but all we really
know
is that this is one of the guys that
they're recruiting for the coalition of
worlds right remember that's their
mission
that we picked up with in the last video
was basically them traveling from world
to world which included even earth
and looking for people that could help
them fight against the villager mites
and that's really all they can do right
it's just find other people that can
help them overcome the vulture mites and
kind of call it a day you do get this
really interesting moment where they're
talking to an older guy
and they ask him like are you looking
for the thompson kid because like they
he's probably in a space station that's
where his family took off to and they're
kind of like you're not really freaked
out by the fact that alan's got like one
eye
and and like i'm in this weird little
get up and the guy's like i mean i've
seen
stranger but usually bad guys don't
knock
it's a pretty sound line of logic to be
honest it works man
and so of course they end up traveling
to this this kind of space station where
you have tech jacket and you have his
dad who both reside now of course when
alan and nolan show up the fact that
they're not bashing the place in
smashing into pieces obviously
illustrates the fact that they're there
essentially as good guys
but tech jacket is an interesting
character because we'll talk about him
in a minute instead what we end up doing
here
is switching back over to the home of
mark and and
debbie and and all that kind of stuff
and all they're all just really kind of
hanging out right all the sort of doing
their thing and talking and whatnot but
mark's brother again he's still pretty
young but one of the things to remember
is he ages at a more rapid pace than
people normally do
and that's why he's aging so fast here
that's why in the last video that we did
the last couple videos he was maybe like
eight or nine years old and now it looks
like he's 15.
because of that you know this is where
he's just kind of at that youthful age
where he's just
really trying to figure himself out for
him it's more difficult and this is
something that's kind of interesting
right you know
sidetrack the story for a second let's
talk about real life right the real life
struggle of a teenager is you are
experiencing an existential crisis
that's all it is
who are you where are you going what are
you about what is the meaning of it all
right what's your purpose in this world
and
in all honesty sure it starts in your
teenage years guys that never ends like
if you guys kind of approached us from
the perspective of like if i don't have
myself totally figured out by the time
i'm 30
i've somehow failed in life well that's
a terrible philosophy like wait until
you get to 30 years old you know what's
gonna happen if you don't have yourself
figured out
the sun is going to rise and the day
will go on
and everything will be okay i didn't
become a youtuber until i was 30. so
i'm 37 years old now so god i've been
doing this for like seven years jesus
time flies man but it's just one of
those things right that the nature of
what it means to be a teenager is to
just kind of panic and to believe that
you're supposed to have it all figured
out you're supposed to have the answers
to everything there's a lot of undue
pressure society puts on you guys but at
the end of the day while society starts
to put that on you
you guys maintain it on yourself and
that's where you really have to break
free of all that but for the for
mark's younger brother the whole thing
here is he wants to go
and he wants to fight in the vulture my
war he wants to go and do that thing
but ultimately a lot of this frustration
comes from the fact that while mark has
talked to his dad
since his dad has been on earth nolan
has not come to see his other son
right he hasn't come to see him at all
and that's kind of a big crushing thing
right because it's one thing when you're
a little kid and you're like okay like
we got to whisk you away and your
brother and your
your you know not really your biological
mom but i guess kind of like
a strange mom more or less is gonna take
care of you uh and then never having
heard from your father and then when he
does come back he talks to your other
brother and doesn't talk to you right
like that's gotta be crushing it's gonna
be a crushing experience but he's not
really approaching this
from from a place of feeling devastated
he's approaching him from a place of
feeling like but why though right it's
really more confusion than
and kind of concerned than anything else
now if this goes on long enough
then it will turn into sadness and it
will turn into anger because at this
point it's kind of like why wouldn't he
want to talk to me give it enough time
it's
god why doesn't he why doesn't he want
to talk to me man and then it's like why
won't he talk to me you know and it's
just it kind of it turns into rage right
and that's the last thing this kid needs
but ultimately mark's whole stance here
is
he's worried about coming around here
because at the end of the day he doesn't
know how things are going to unfold he
doesn't know if he's ready to see mom
yet and he doesn't know if he's ready to
tell her about all this and so we might
be able to arrange a meeting of sorts
but at the moment that's why he hasn't
come around here
at that moment debbie walks in and she's
like what are you guys talking about
like what do you want to what do you not
want to tell me about and who is it
that's not ready to see me and then just
words off the side of the screen me but
i've since changed my mind
nolan has come back home no one has come
to see his wife
and i know you guys knew what was coming
i know you guys knew it was only a
matter of time before it was coming now
here's the thing
the exchange is incredibly short this is
kind of this is writing genius of robert
kirkman right you read comic books long
enough one of the things you learn to
appreciate is the salvo
this whole concept of like nolan and
debbie are talking again
but only for a moment because then what
it does is it gives you this desire to
like see them converse right because we
they haven't talked
since like nolan left earth since
everything popped off she learned the
truth about what was going on
when the whole footage and everything
was released to social media like she
learned about all that stuff and they
and she hasn't seen or heard from him
since so there's a lot of pent up anger
and a lot of pent up irritation there
the first thing he does is apologize and
rightfully so he literally
married her under false pretenses right
he was a guy who was sent to earth to
conquer it now ultimately he ended up
falling in love with her and everything
changed and that's what he said he's
like my time here has changed me
all those years i spent with you raising
mark our life together i thought it was
an act i thought i was pretending to be
something that i wasn't but i was wrong
i was changing becoming the person that
you knew what we shaped together
was real when i fought mark i learned
the truth i was forcing myself to carry
out my mission
that was an act that it was the it was
the the whole thing being turned on its
head that in reality the person he was
pretending to be
is the person he became and that's
what's so interesting right it's kind of
the gift of humanity that robert kirkman
sort of hits on here that despite some
of the bleak moments that you see in
invincible
that it really kind of hits this idea
that from the perspective of somebody
like nolan humanity has this sort of
grandness about it right this sort of
innocence that the rest of the universe
simply just doesn't have
but at the end of the day while he
apologizes and he's like i've grown to
love you she just interrupts him and
stops him and says i don't
i don't think i can ever really believe
any of that nolan and how could i
possibly believe any of that stuff and
at that moment he's like okay fine i
understand he says i'm sorry
and he ultimately leaves now from there
you switch over to tech jacket basically
talking to alan alien and the reason why
you haven't really seen tech jacket is
as is explained
his job is to basically monitor
extraterrestrial threats from beyond the
stars right so that's why you you kind
of see him at like great big huge events
but you don't really see him in
day-to-day stuff it's pretty smart to
just kind of a stroke of the pen and
that's why you don't really see him all
that often but it is kind of a cool
thing right he's not a traditional
superhero but he is certainly somebody
capable of handling like
threats beyond the planet earth right so
he's definitely somebody the coalition
wants to have
on their side now at that moment we
switch over to nolan
talking to his son now for oliver it's a
little bit awkward man
not gonna lie it's a little bit strange
because he's never really had a
conversation like this with his dad
because he was so young when he was
taken away it's one of these things
where he's never really had a true
conversation with his father the funny
thing about this is nolan kind of
approaches it as if it's just kind of
another day i mean he does
you do kind of get the significance that
nolan hasn't seen a son in a long long
time but it's one of these things where
it's like let's just kind of pick up
where we left off
and the reality is that oliver's excited
for that but in a lot of instances and
i've experienced that too when you had a
parent kind of bail
that is one of these things where it's
like but you can't pick up where you
left off
right like where you left off was years
ago right where where we are now is
completely different but for oliver the
desire to understand and to meet with
his father
is so intense it doesn't matter to him
how long it's been his father's back now
and his father
wants to talk to him right and that's
kind of the cool thing here is
it would have been very easy for nolan
to say okay like we'll have time
together son but for now
i need to go take off and i need to
fight this threat much like what you saw
him doing with mark pretty consistently
instead it's one of these things where
parents basically fix mistakes that they
made when they had their first kids
when it comes to ancillary kids right
second kids third kids fourth kid so on
and so forth you know for for oliver
like his father extends on the
invitation and says you know what why
don't you come with us
right why don't you come with us on this
trip and then i can learn to understand
you better and like that's exactly what
oliver wanted to hear because what it
puts off is
my dad wants to spend time with me from
there you switch over to a pretty tender
moment between
uh adam eve and mark right because
remember eve knew this was coming she
knew it was only gonna be a matter of
time before the vulture might war
officially kicked
off and mark had to go and so when mark
shows up all he says is
it's time and that's all that needs to
be said right so of course they share
the night together and he's like i don't
know when i'm going to be coming back or
if i'm even going to be coming back and
of course eve doesn't want to hear that
but that's the reality of the situation
right this vulture might war
that mark is going to fight him he may
not come back he may not survive
we've seen how he's faced off against
other members of the vulture might race
and it didn't go very well
right now we're talking about him waging
war against the entire
empire right it's gonna be big it's it's
a massive thing and so in the face of
that
while she is really trying to kind of
blow it off and say no you know no no no
that's never gonna happen
mark's really kind of holding his ground
and really facing reality here and
saying but that's something that you
need to accept
the people here that we're going to be
fighting are a lot more powerful than i
am i don't know if i'm powerful enough
to defeat these guys
i don't know for sure that i'm going to
survive this but at the end of the day
that's what needs to happen right you
need to understand that and so
ultimately eve cuts them off and then
just says like i don't want to focus on
that for right now i just want to focus
on us right if you're going to have to
leave soon then let these moments that
we have together be these just
amazing moments so that if you end up
dying this is what i can recall
our last time together being the
downside of this of course is that as
mark starts to fall asleep eve starts to
ball
because she's facing the fact that she
might lose mark right that mark might
die which is really a testament to how
much she loves him right eve adores that
guy she
she's ahead of her heels form and so
from there you basically switch over to
mark and oliver and nolan who are all
just kind of hanging out which is pretty
cool
to see like the father and son team just
kind of working together like yeah
we're gonna fight a race of superman and
we might die but it's gonna be cool like
um
i think that's awesome i think that's
pretty pretty cool but of course the
they have is also a very a ship
full of incompetent people but the
reality and the reason why they need
this ship because a lot of guys are
probably asking
if they can hold their breath for a
really long time why don't they just fly
there because the journey is very very
long and that it would take longer
for really for them to fly there and
they may not be able to hold their
breath long enough they might be able to
come across a couple planets here and
there but the reality is the universe is
a big place
and the amount of knowledge it would
take for a person to know exactly where
they need to stop
and to be able to chart that effectively
based on their abilities is
quite large right the amount of time it
would be kind of insane and so it's
actually easier for them to basically
just kind of stow aboard a ship or to
use the ship that was given to them by
the coalition and just kind of go
forward from there the problem is that
in the middle of all this while they're
basically flying it's wham right it's
like a red alert and everything starts
popping off right
and then like like literally like some
targets coming in like super fast right
like it's fat like i've never seen
anything this fast before
break for impact and like the ship just
explodes
right just gets smashed to pieces the
bridge of the ship initiates this
automatic sequence right where it just
like detaches
from the rest of the ship itself so the
bridge basically kind of goes flying
through space but they're like what in
the hell just happened and it's like i
don't know man but like whatever it was
it hit us and the ship just basically
broke apart now
mark's dad is back there right nolan's
back there and the fear is that nolan's
died the reality is that as soon as mark
gets out there and starts looking around
you've got conquest and you got a couple
other vulture mites with him and the
vulture might war has officially begun
but the real question you have to ask
here
is that where mark is getting ready to
fight this guy what happens to conquest
when nolan gets his hands on because i'm
gonna tell you right now what mark did
is nothing compared to what this poor
bastard's about to go through but that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace